the boys are finally back going where no
superhero show dares to go that's a
penis from the world's saddest hand job
the nation's next hottest video game and
the freshest of calamari the first three
episodes pack a ton of cool easter eggs
and clues for what's going to happen
next so follow me down to brave maze
inclusive kingdom and make sure to put
your preferred pronouns in the comments
section because here we go the dawn of
the seven movie has finally released
after extensive rewrites were required
after was revealed stormfront was an
actual nazi you may remember her filming
alongside other members of the seven
last season but vaught has come a long
way since its founder frederik vaught a
literal nazi who experimented on jews in
world war ii founded a company which now
preaches inclusivity don't forget your
blm blts thus reshoots were required
with charlize theron taking on the nazi
[ __ ] role you'll remember at the end of
season 2 stormfront was burnt to a crisp
by homelander and becca's son ryan where
it's later revealed she's currently
recovering in homelanders apartment even
with all the backlash against her she
still has a group of loyal followers
called the storm chasers we'll see them
carrying around tiki torches just like
real-life white supremacists did in
charlottesville back in 2017. this whole
opening segment is a spoof on zack
snyder's justice league with the movie
even getting its own
the releasethebortcut which will
hopefully drop on vot plus you can watch
the trailer for the movie as well as an
ad for vot plus on the vaut
international youtube channel which has
exclusive content including several
segments from america's favorite
unbiased anchor cameron coleman a satire
on fox news anchors like tucker carlson
and sean hannity i personally am sick
and tired of the continued attacks by
the leftist pc snowflakes do it live
[Music]
now you may have noticed there are only
five members of the seven here with the
deep end storm front no longer a part
even the production design highlights
this as the background paneling here in
episode two only shows five of the seven
members the two new members become a
major plot point for starlight in the
first three episodes where she holds a
reality tv show called american hero in
which 10 supes battle for the two open
slots one of the contestants being super
sonic a former fling of starlights who
she met during her capes for christ days
you might remember this guy ezekiel
headlining a capes for christ convention
back in season one and on the vnn
channel we learn he's being investigated
by the federal bureau of superhero
affairs for let's just say not being
very christian the fbsa is where we find
huey working at the beginning of episode
1. he's congresswoman victoria newman's
right-hand man in charge of
investigating and holding supes
accountable for their crimes and since
the bureau's inception there's been a 60
decrease in collateral deaths involving
supes remember that huey's girlfriend
from season one was one such instance of
a collateral death with a train blasting
right through her and facing almost zero
repercussions we'll even get a slight
nod to her in mother milk's
investigation closet this movie premiere
is a triggering event for homelander who
has to watch the love of his life
exposed on the big screen not to mention
he's being outshone by starlight
homelander has been smeared in the media
for his relationship with a nazi and
he's been trained by vaught with
specific talking points he repeats these
on multiple networks this is just like
in real life how giant media companies
promote their message to the masses and
how we as a society can be easily
manipulated by it the sharing of bias
false news
meanwhile huey keeps tabs on a man named
tony someone who says he is victoria
newman's best friend or as he calls her
a nadia we'll later find out tony and
victoria grew up in a sort of orphanage
for soup kids known as red river and
when he confronts her about it saying
they need to come forward about red
river he ends up like a literal red
river here's where we can start getting
into some theories red river was a joint
operation between the government and
vaught that's probably how stan edgar
gained access to young nadia a girl he
calls quote very special and ends up
adopting stan has always struck me as a
very calculating man and i can't help
but think there's something more here
choosing nadia as his daughter in the
boys animated spin-off red river is
shown in episode 2 as being a sort of
orphanage for unwanted supes which
tracks here but the comics imply red
river is a sort of independent military
contractor hence why its name is so
close to blackwater a notorious
real-life contractor involved in many
instances of incompetence and use of
excessive force so maybe red river is
like a type of recruiting front for vot
taking the most vulnerable of soups
those orphaned under its wing with tony
wanting to come forward with what was
happening to them there maybe various
experiments or other nefarious things
happened at the end of episode 1 huey
watches as victoria explodes tony then
calling stan edgar to have the place
cleaned up this is probably what
happened after the church of the
collective's leader alastair adana's
head was popped off after enjoying a
delicious fresca vott came in cleaned
the place up and according to vienna
news no one has seen adana since a train
storyline these three episodes hasn't
really picked up the pace and yes my
puns are terrible he's struggling with
his own identity after the one thing
that made him who he was his speed can't
really be used anymore for fear his
heart will explode while visiting the
doctor in episode 3 he'll be told that
if he uses his power it'll be like
russian roulette whether he'll die or
not this is why we've seen him try to
pivot to different careers like a rapper
in his own music video or even
rebranding his image with the
introduction of his brother this season
it looks like a train will have to
decide on leaving the seven and his life
as a superhero for one more down to
earth and family oriented they also
introduced this new soup called blue
hawk who apparently has been hunting
down innocent black men on vnn we
learned he has his own cop style reality
show i wonder if we'll see atrain turn
away from the glitz and glamour of the
seven to helping his community bork rips
out ashley's hair while doing the freak
nasty at the dawn premiere just another
instance in which ashley's hair has
fallen out throughout the series and i
gotta say i love how ashley's new
assistant is actually called also ashley
in the credits butcher frenchie and
kimiko are the only remaining members of
the boys working in tandem with huey at
the fbsa to bring down corrupt soups one
such corrupt superhero is termite an
actor who starred in the beloved rom-com
pocket romance not only is this a great
reintroduction to the boys but it also
sets up the corruption between vaut and
the government with huey becoming
disillusioned when termite goes free due
to a deal that was made between vaut and
the fbsa we'll see huey go from
believing he's actually making a
difference by doing things the right way
to later telling butcher they can never
win that way i thought we could
fight about the right way but we can't
it's all rigged if we're gonna take them
down
we have to do whatever it takes if this
is part of his character arc this season
just watch it bite him in the ass and it
may even end up with him losing
starlight the deep connection between
vaut and the government is showcased
between vaught president stan edgar and
u.s presidential hopeful robert singer
we've seen him in the past seasons when
he was secretary of defense stan tells
him of this new compound v that only
lasts 24 hours if and when it is fully
perfected it should be a win-win for
both parties the government won't have
to deal with the lingering effects of
lifetime superheroes their powers would
only last 24 hours and vaught could sell
this compound at 2 million a pop over
and over again stan also believes that
when vaughn turned the super into a hero
something to be worshipped it ruined
them and he lets it slide that he hopes
to retire in five years i wouldn't
really count on that maeve will somehow
get our hands on three of these 24-hour
compound v vials and gives them to
butcher he's the perfect character to
take this drug as he'll literally turn
into the thing he hates more than
anything supes if i were to make a guess
the writers will be going on an
addiction arc with him we've already
seen how the drug has started to
fracture relationships with people he
loves like ryan we've also seen the
physical side effects kimiko is going
through her own problems dreaming of
being able to sing and later telling
ryan that she thinks she's a monster at
vaughtland which is actually canada's
wonderland just outside of toronto she
sees a brother and sister experience the
traumatic event of crimson countess
exploding a homeland or mascot and it
reminds her of the trauma she and her
brother experienced as kids a brother
who died at the hands of stormfront last
season i wonder if they're setting
kimiko up to regain her voice but in the
process lose her power i've heard there
is a musical episode this season so who
knows speaking of music i love how the
end of episode 1 finished with billy
joel playing in the background a call
back to huey's billy joel dance parties
he'd have with his mom when he was six i
wonder if she'll make an appearance this
season ryan is plagued by nightmares of
his father homelander but butcher
reassures him that someday he'll be
strong enough where he can't hurt him
with all this talk of a special weapon
the one that supposedly killed soldier
boy being the thing that could kill
homelander i really don't buy it for one
we know from the previews that soldier
boy is alive so whether or not such a
weapon exists is up in the air and two i
just think it would be narratively
better if the power to kill homelander
came from his own son mother's milk has
his own journey which leads him back to
the boys in these first three episodes
the guy has to watch his daughter host a
superhero themed party when he knows how
corrupt all of them are and what a great
dad getting his daughter what any girl
would want a flavorflave clock adding
salt to the wound is his ex-wife's
current lover todd who wears a
homelander costume we'll later see todd
brimming with excitement when homelander
gives his unhinged speech one which ups
his favorability with white males and
the rust belt by 44
these ratings are the bread and butter
of vaught and dictate which direction
the company goes starlade is made a
co-captain of the seven for her 96
rating contrasted with homelanders
plummeting numbers in the eyes of the
public she and maeve were responsible
for catching stormfront she has this
wholesome image and the people like her
relationship with huey a non-soup of
course when homelander isn't the center
of attention it means trouble for well
anyone but him two things have been
keeping homelander in check stan edgar
and this damning footage of homelander
allowing the plane from season 1 to
crash with dozens of civilians on board
when starlight threatens to release this
tape homelander says then he'll have
nothing to lose and if he has nothing to
lose then he'll basically destroy the
world that's how powerful this guy is
and adds stakes to why it's so important
the boys find a way to stop him
homelander here also refers to himself
as the homelander his original name
which had the the dropped years ago by
madeleine stillwell because it sounded
better this is all part of him taking
control back for himself mother's milk's
arc is one of moving on he needs to live
his own life but when he finds out the
boys are hunting down soldier boy the
man who killed his family he can't let
it go the deep rises from record low
approval ratings to one so high he's
eventually brought back into the seven
his message of being reformed is one
that resonates with audiences he even
had time to star in a movie with billy
zane called not without my dolphin funny
enough this isn't billy's first bought
feature he started with popclaw in
terminal beauty 3. as homelander
prepares for his annual televised
birthday extravaganza he learns about
stormfront suicide she doesn't wish him
a happy birthday and her realization
that homelander never really cared about
this white master race only himself this
is what pushes her over the edge so if
there is this weapon that could kill
homeland or the boys decide to look into
soldier boy's team a team called payback
maybe they know what really happened to
soldier boy in this weapon which
supposedly killed him the mainstream
narrative is that soldier boy was killed
stopping a nuclear reactor from going
off but the reality is far more
nefarious payback was the leading
superhero group prior to the seven and
included soldier boy crimson countess
mindstorm swatto who has to be a
reference to watto the tnt twins and
black noir in fact black noir would go
on to become the leader of the seven a
rule which would later be taken over by
homelander black noir gets a little bit
of an origin story as well where we see
the injury he sustained which gave him
burns and what i also think gave him the
inability to speak the irony here is
that the last conversation he had with
stan edgar was all about how he no
longer wanted to wear his mask but now
with the disfigurement he reaches for it
only by beating the [ __ ] out of
gunpowder does butcher find out none
other than grace mallory was the
official in charge of the nicaraguan
mission which brought about soldier
boy's death in the 80s the u.s
government and payback worked together
to sell cocaine in order to finance the
government's war against the
russian-backed sandinistas the whole
mission was a failure with soldier boy's
dead body picked up by the russians we
do know soldier boy is alive from the
previews and judging by the carnage he
gets up to i wonder if there's a whole
winter soldier type thing going on here
where soldier boy was revived and
brainwashed by the russians or this
could totally be a ruse we never really
see what happened to soldier boy and the
person we get this info from is soldier
boy's girlfriend the crimson countess
who by the way is a washed up superhero
who performs for small near-empty crowds
at an amusement park although her hit
song chimps don't cry is a banger you
know the chimps are physically incapable
of crying the operation in nicaragua
also known as operation charlie is based
off a real operation in south america in
which the united states backed
right-wing dictatorships it's here we
get our first look at young stan edgar
in charge of managing the payback team
he's hoping to prove that supes can be
used in the military something that even
in the present day hasn't been approved
now huey investigates red river where he
sees this boy named teddy stillwell
which was the name of madeleine
stillwell's infant son in season one
with his mother dead at the hands or
should i say eyes of homelander it looks
like this is where he ended up it's by
grabbing red river's files that huey
learns not only about victoria newman's
past it looks as though she may have
killed her parents or others as a child
bonus points if he caught the gal gear
adds in the back of the vaught rifle
association which was seen on vnn or
gunpowder's second amendment forever
license plate butcher ends up viciously
killing gunpowder but i also got the
vibe that he wasn't in particular
control of this power almost as if this
compound is making him more aggressive
kind of like what happens to dudes who
take steroids but let me know what you
think in the comments below the end of
the second episode culminates in this
unhinged speech in which homelander
talks about being controlled his whole
life and that it's his turn to take
control this is the first time he's
being real and genuine which resonates
with a lot of his followers what was
originally seen as something that would
tank his ratings turns out to do the
opposite now episode 3 is pretty cool
because it both starts and ends with
starlight's clenched fist one when she
was a small girl competing in little
miss hero pageants and one as an adult
in both instances you have other people
dictating her life as a child it was her
mother and now homelander who drops the
bombshell that he and starlight are
dating this is all a vain attempt to
gain his fame back while also
psychologically torturing starlight he's
even instrumental in bringing back the
deep into the seven who notoriously
sexually assaulted starlight back in
season one with huey and mother's milk
both back with the boys you might have
noticed the name of their base graywall
and company named after the late
darvinder greywall the boys production
designer who died in 2020. hughie has
his arm broken by kimiko so he'll have
an excuse to call in sick and hopefully
not raise victoria newman's suspicions
that he's on to her speaking of victoria
she knows where ryan is being held so
that also means stan edgar does too so
the boys have him moved this is where
butcher is incredibly cruel to ryan who
has since looked up to him as a father
figure ryan even made a cute stop and go
lego video which had butcher's ex-wife's
voice in it for ryan this is incredibly
hurtful and for a moment he shows his
red eyes as if he's going to retaliate
we saw what happened when homelander was
raised without a father figure maybe
butcher needs to learn to fulfill that
role not only for ryan's good but for
himself we'll also see ryan drop his
necklace of saint christopher a present
given to him by butcher at the end of
season 2. the legend of saint
christopher tells the story of a man who
helped a small child across a river only
for it to be revealed that the child is
christ so this is symbolic of butcher
turning away from being that person if
ryan is to be this christ-like figure
frenchie goes on a mission of his own
when he finds out his good friend sherry
is on the run for stealing from the
russian mob particularly a woman named
little nina in the comics she is
depicted as extremely short with an
affinity for vibrators and is later
killed when butcher plants an explosive
in one of them this may tie into the
action from one of the trailers which
shows kimiko using dildos as weapons in
an absolutely disgusting scene where the
deep has to eat his own octopus and
friend named timothy homelander compares
his struggle to that of martin luther
king hilarious considering he loved a
white supremacist and hates any sort of
marginalized group captain al qaeda
we're americans but this all seems to be
leading to homelander becoming more and
more powerful narcissistic and unruly so
it's all becoming a race against time
for the boys to find a way to stop him
once and for all butcher says he'll use
little nina as their way into russia
maybe she'll have information about
soldier boy's whereabouts we do know
that butcher kimiko and frenchie will
make it to wherever soldier boy has been
hiding by the looks of it in some sort
of cryostasis i'm really looking forward
to when soldier boy is finally released
and homelander will truly have someone
to rival him thanks a lot for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and let me know your thoughts and
theories for episodes one to three for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember you're gonna
say vagina